So, if you've been living under a rock,
you may not know that one of the most
despicable lawsuits in YouTube history
is currently being undertaken by Ethan
Klein against one Noah Samson, a lefty
sort of breadtube video essayist who's
very pro-Palestine and very anti-Israel.
He released a video just over a year ago
now called The YouTubers Who Backed the
Genocide. It was about Ethan Klein. It
was about Destiny. It was about all
these guys. And he basically pitches
that through selective coverage, through
you know, misinfo they've spread,
through through various different
things,
uh these YouTubers have aided or
supported or engaged in rhetoric that
backs a genocide. And that's a that's a
totally reasonable opinion to have based
on the evidence. Totally reasonable
opinion to have based on the evidence.
Totally justifiable. I challenge people
to actually rebut Noah Samson's video.
Loabster Box did not do a very good job
when he tried. And the defamatory
claims, the alleged defamatory claims in
the lawsuit are absurd. One of them, for
instance, is that Noah Samson used a
dishonestly cropped picture of Ethan to
make it appear like he was doing a Nazi
salute to the Israeli flag when in
actuality he had just used the exact
same still of Ethan from the Content
Nuke thumbnail and placed it over an
image of ruined Gaza with an Israeli
flag in the middle of it. So, totally
erroneous claims, totally absurd claims
that have been made against Noah here.
And it's just despicable that a YouTuber
is first of all trying to
use resources this way. Also, that
anyone, frankly, is trying to litigate
criticism of Israel like that and
litigate criticism of media surrounding
Israel through the courtroom. That there
isn't a
claim that I can see as defamatory in
there. It does seem like opinion.
And even to the extent that there are
factual claims, they seem to be either
correct or they're like sort of disputed
arguments about like international law
or about, you know, which piece of
reporting is more accurate. It's not uh
or lying. There's there's, you know,
most of it is not claims of fact, it's
opinion. So, I I just don't see the
argument really. It's totally absurd to
me. It's just a disgusting use of the
legal system. Obviously, Keemstar has
already been has already been uh bullied
into silence essentially for signing a
non-disparagement agreement. Brogan, I
believe has just defaulted on her
lawsuit because she hadn't replied to
it. And Denims is still fighting hers.
Now, Ethan Klein has used quite a
despicable trick on Denims because
obviously he registered the content nuke
before its release uh laying this trap.
Now, Denims did like a 3-hour reaction
to the content nuke. It was actually
quite transformative as she was replying
to the points in them. So, what Ethan
did is Ethan then, when he decided to
sue her, registered the countdown stream
to the content nuke with the Library of
Congress as well so that he could try
and get statutory damages on that. So,
the despite presenting it as being about
like prepared content that people have
put a lot of work into on his uh initial
video announcing the suits. If you
actually look into it, it's not really
what he's suing for. So, it's genuinely
some of the most low-life behavior I've
ever seen online. It risks having
massive impacts on free speech, massive
impacts on your speech online, massive
impacts on the speech of YouTubers you
may watch. Uh it's honestly just some of
the most low-life behavior. No one can
come up with a reasonable argument
against it. They just they just cry that
oh, "Keemstar's really bad person. Noah
Samsun's really bad person. They're
lefties. They're tankies." That's all
they can do. That's all they can do.
They just appeal to the unpopularity of
the person involved, and that's why
Ethan's picked them cuz they're soft
targets. They they haven't been involved
in any of the harassment against his
family as far as he's shown. It's just
totally absurd. So, let's just take a
look. Noah Samsun has just uploaded a
video called Ethan Klein is suing me.
So, let's have a look. It's official.
It's happening. I am getting sued by
Ethan Klein. Ethan Klein, millionaire
and host of the H3 Podcast, has sued me
for defamation. Here's the complaint.
It's 31 pages, and I'm getting sued.
About a year ago, I released this video.
So this is So this is the image here,
guys. It's being claimed to be a Nazi
salute. Obviously, we go to just the
content new quickly. You can see here,
it's the exact same still. It's just
trimmed out. of the YouTubers who backed
genocide. And in response, Ethan Klein
immediately began threatening to sue me.
Then, a year later, just 2 days before
the statute of limitations was up, Klein
filed his lawsuit. In the complaint,
Klein alleges that I defamed him by
falsely painting him as a supporter of
the genocide of Palestinians. The
complaint presents six allegedly
defamatory statements, including the
title and thumbnail of my video, and it
makes several claims related to
statements made about Israel, Palestine,
atrocity propaganda, Nakba denialism,
misinformation, and more. lot of stuff
in this thing. It's 31 pages. For now,
all I can say about the lawsuit itself
is that I think Ethan's claims are
meritless and I intend to defend against
them. But to do this, I need your help.
A full-length defamation trial can cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars, and I
don't have that. So, I started a
GoFundMe. It's linked [music] in the
description and the pinned comment. You
can also find it by searching Klein v.
Samson on the internet. I set the goal
at $200,000, but any funds we raise
above this goal will be donated
immediately to Palestinian aid. And any
money that goes unused or is Or um
I don't like that commitment. No, commit
it all to your defense, please. Commit
it all to your defense. If anything's
left over, give that to Palestine, okay?
Like, how about we focus on your speech,
Allah? That's what I would prefer. You
know, I
I think Palestine should be donated to
as well, but um I would really prefer if
no one just focused on winning this
[__] lawsuit, cuz this is like really
bad for for a lot of us, okay? For a lot
of us. I really prefer if no one just
focused on winning this lawsuit, but
hey. recuperated once legal proceedings
conclude will also be donated. Last
year, around the time of Ethan's initial
lawsuit threats, we did a fundraiser for
UNRWA, an organization that provides aid
to Palestinians.
>> You've already done the Palestine thing,
man. This one's for you, okay? This
one's for you. refugees
>> And we raised over half a million
dollars, so it would [music] be cool if
we could do something like that again.
I'll be hosting a fundraising live
stream this Friday, May 22nd, starting
at 10:00 a.m. Pacific time. It's a
marathon stream, so it will go for 4
days straight, maybe longer. We'll have
lots of guests calling in to hang out,
play games, or do tier lists, or
whatever else. So far, we've got FD
Signifier, Boyinaband, Big Joel, Denims,
iDubbbz, Frogan, Elliot Sang, Chris
Cunslor, Overlord Zalt, Spooky Scary
Socialist, Ahmed Zarsour, Color Mind,
Oli Sun Via, Cavernacle, and more. We'll
have lots of fun donation goals. You may
get to see me chug a gallon of milk,
take a pie to the face, wax my legs,
cosplay your favorite influencer, do the
hot chip challenge, run a marathon, and
more.
>> Dude, if he does like a Destiny cosplay
and just like Destiny impressions and
[__] like that, that'll get crazy.
That'll get crazy. Can we be honest? Can
we be honest? What if he does like a
really anti-Semitic Ethan Klein cosplay?
That'd get crazy. That'd be awesome. Put
some makeup and wear fake nose on.
Thanks. Cosplay your favorite
influencer, do the hot chip challenge,
run a marathon, and more. We'll have the
wheel going as well, like we did during
the last fundraiser. And for the grand
finale, if we hit $500,000,
I will ride a bike 120 miles from San
Diego to Hasan Piker's house to beg him
for more money. Klein v. Samson GoFundMe
link in bio. Donate to help defend free
speech on YouTube and send money to
Palestinian [music] Aid as well while we
do it. Thanks for watching. See you on
Friday. So, just a short video there,
guys. So, on Friday, so tomorrow, uh
Noah will be streaming. Well, it's
tomorrow for me, I don't know about you
guys. Uh
about, you know, over 24 hours, just
over 24 hours, Noah will be streaming a
fundraiser for his lawsuit, guys. So,
I'm going to link his GoFundMe in the
chat. If you've got, uh you know, $20 to
help protect free speech, um
that'd be awesome if you went and
donated to Noah Samson. He's raised
$43,000 so far, and the live stream has
not even started.
Which is a good start. Yeah, stop. Don't
get my door dash order. Stop. Don't need
to know how Samsung got phone me. Give
me another 50 bucks.
So, yeah, absolutely critical support
for those Samsung. You may not like the
guy.
I I honestly don't have that crazy of an
opinion. I mean, it's got like, yeah,
the child predator stuff. Kind of
cringe, kind of funny. Yeah, makes bank.
Um,
I don't I don't have like crazy negative
opinion on the guy. I used to really not
like the guy, but honestly, after I
watched a few more of his videos, seeing
that he was in the right on a couple of
things. It's like, you know, I don't
really him that much. Um, and he's
fighting for this. He's fighting this.
So, big respect, massive respect
fighting a lawsuit like this. And yeah,
absolutely critical support for this
guy. Absolutely [music] critical.